los organismos internacionales no han
podido entrar a la región de tigre a
pesar de que la onu y el gobierno
federal de etiopía pactaron el acceso
humanitario hace tres días la oficina de
naciones unidas para los refugiados
explicó que está discutiendo con el
gobierno etíope la logística y la
seguridad y mientras eso ocurre cerca de
100.000 eritreos refugiados en tigre se
quedan sin comida y seguimos recibiendo
informes preocupantes sobre los campos
de refugiados eritreos en la región que
permanecen incomunicados los detalles de
los daños y las interrupciones siguen
sin conocerse hasta que podamos llegar a
ellos y verificar la información
lista de information
el conflicto deja casi 50.000 refugiados
en sudan en cuanto a tigre nadie sabe a
ciencia cierta qué está ocurriendo
amnistía internacional reportó una
masacre en la que al menos 600 personas
fueron asesinadas con machetes en
noviembre testigos culpan a las fuerzas
de tigre france24 le pregunto sobre esto
al líder regional en desconectado el
gobierno y el frente de liberación
popular de tigre han sido acusados de
matar a civiles que puede contestar
estamos en nuestra casa son nuestras
tierras
los invasores nos atacan desde el cielo
o con su artillería en el campo de
batalla con sus soldados los civiles no
pueden ser atacados por nosotros
el presidente de la región denuncia que
el gobierno de eritrea está combatiendo
junto a los militares etíopes y los
líderes de tigre- acusan al ejército
federal de saquear las casas las fuerzas
oficiales por su parte dicen que ya
capturaron o mataron a la mayoría de
comandantes de tigre pero ante la falta
de acceso nada se ha comprobado de
manera independiente